You can now access all of the Sequence Read
Archive's vast public and controlled-access
human datasets in the cloud, transforming
any laptop into a high performance computing
device, and can ease struggles with speed
and storage issues you might encounter using
FTP to download large datasets from the NCBI.
This short video demonstrates the steps needed
to access public SRA data with Amazon Web
Services.
At the end of the video you can link to a
companion video describing access through
Google Cloud Platform.
I'll cover these three activities:
1) Setting up a new cloud instance
2) Downloading and installing the SRA Toolkit
within your instance
3) Configuring and testing the Toolkit installation.
To set up a new cloud instance, start with
Amazon Elastic Compute Cloud (EC2).
If you are new to AWS, or just want to try
out accessing SRA data, the Free tier is a
good option.
I've logged in to my account, and I'll launch
a new instance.
For this demo I'll select the first Linux
server, accept the t2.mirco instance type,
go to Review and Launch.
I'll accept the defaults, but be aware that
you may want to edit the Security Group.
And make sure that the region is set to us-east-1
in Northern Virginia for efficient, and free,
data retrieval from the SRA.
Okay, I'll click Launch, select a key pair
option, and in a few minutes my instance is
running.
I'll connect to my instance using an SSH client,
following the handy instructions right here.
The next steps are to download and install
the SRA Toolkit, and those steps are nicely
laid out in our github wiki at ncbi/sra-tools,
including installing and configuration.
I downloaded and installed the latest version,
2.10.3
And I now want to show you in detail how to
configure the toolkit, because there are a
few critical steps required to access these
public data in the cloud.
Type vdb-config -i to get an interactive display
for the configuration.
The first requirement is to enable remote
access, which should be selected by default.
You can navigate this config menu either by
tab or underlined letter.
Type c, and you can decide whether you want
data cached locally or not, and where you
want it cached.
If local cache is enabled, be sure that you
specify a directory with sufficient disk space.
The next two settings are critical.
Type a to set AWS as the cloud provider, and
type r to set report cloud instance identity.
That's it for configuring access.
I'll type s then o to save, and x to exit.
If you want to review these steps in more
detail, see section 05 Toolkit Configuration
on the github wiki page.
Let's run a quick test of our toolkit installation.
Type fasterq-dump and an SRR accession (SRR5368359)
This run takes several seconds to retrieve,
And there are the two fastq files.
That's all for this demo.
We’d love to have your feedback and questions.
For help with SRA data and the toolkit, write
to sra@ncbi.nlm.nih.gov.
For feedback and other questions, please write
to suggest@ncbi.nlm.nih.gov